We're going to watch some of Yori's
coverage here.
Honestly, I've seen a bit of it already.
It's It's not that interesting. It's not
that remarkable.
He does just go through the evidence
pretty much. Um the takes are pretty
obvious here,
you know. Uh I don't think there's much
disagreement really
about like the factual basis and how
supported or evidence that it is.
So, the main stuff that's in this Dior
stream
is one, he lays out red lines for his
associations with Tom and which
allegations he thinks Tom absolutely has
to respond to,
which is interesting.
And you also we also get to hear Dioro
talk about sex, which is awesome. So,
we're going to take a look. We're going
to have a laugh. Let's see what we
think.
I can't get past the music.
>> We're just going to do it. We're just
going to go down.
>> Anyone notice that the same people that
hate Kiwi Farms because they took down
Keles are now praising Kiwi Farms for
these allegations?
>> Well, one minute. You say Nicholas
Duro's a virgin, but um I saw a clip
where
he he told a story.
If I can find this where he said this,
>> this was just something in the heat of
the moment. And then she just put her
finger in my ass.
Not really. I didn't see that. Is that
happening? That I was not aware of. All
right. Hi, Kiwi people. I dated Tom for
a few months after meeting him on
Tinder. That was his first mistake. I'm
not super into internet stuff and I had
no idea what Kiwi Farms was, but this
page was his always number one search
Safari thing that pops up on his phone
when he went to Google something. That's
a great start. That's an awesome start.
When I asked about his website, he got
super defensive and weird about it. So,
I obviously looked into it and found all
of this crazy [__] like him admitting to
being bisexual.
Is Tom is bisexual.
I think he said that right like
publicly. Is he?
I don't know, dude. I'm so [__] If he
is, that's like really good news because
that means that that's another
commentary 2026 thing down, right? If
Tom's actually bisexual, then that means
we have Aiden and Tom
and we have a person becoming a
different sexuality. So, we're done. The
rest of the year should be smooth
sailing. Is that it? I have no idea. I
thought he I I was under the
>> Nicholas the goat. Thank you for the $5.
>> The only time I've ever heard about
Turkey Tom being bisexual is that
somebody said there was like an old clip
of him saying it in a video. If that's
not the case, then I don't know. Message
the owner of the website Joshua Moon to
get a code to post here. Basically, I
started to get suspicious about all the
eirls he's followed and interacted with,
and he started raging at me. He also
lied to me first about the fact that he
does YouTube.
What? All right.
Um, how do you not know he does?
>> We're going to speed this up because
it's a Doro stream. So, obviously, so
much of it is just like performative
retardation and [__] like that. So,
>> okay. I mean, I guess that's possible.
Maybe people aren't inquisitive. He did
some crazy [__] like kicked holes in the
wall at a house he was renting because
some e-girl who copies Bel Delian got
hacked and the hacker was blackmailing
him with the Oh
well um I don't know this is my coping
mode I would be like I'd probably take a
hole through the wall too if my penis if
my pener was going to leak on the
internet. He continued to talk to me
after the fact. I have screenshots
confirming all this and attached to a
couple of but I might have more.
>> Nicholas the goat. Thank you for the $5,
my man.
>> So this guy had he had a destiny moment
then. He had a destiny moment. Only the
nudes were like only of him. My gosh.
Um, the fact that this guy is a real
freak and he likes to record sexual
account.
>> Usually when a guy is by, you expect him
to be softer and understanding.
I just I don't even know how to
respond to a chat message like that. I
think you're expecting to be like some
sexual degenerate pervert. Actually,
>> without asking first, almost every time.
I know for a fact he's done this to at
least one other girl, a serial gooner.
>> I just saw Ke's tweet on Nicholas
>> and he's flown out several e girls to
sleep with. He told me he has a file on
his computer called Just in case. That's
basically voice messes or calls from his
exes to blackmail them in case they ever
say something about him. Though I would
get the message out, sorry, I thought I
would get the message out and confirm
y'all's suspicions. Also, if this gets
out to warn other young women in the
Texas area about this guy.
>> So, there's two things I want to hit
before we move down from here. Um,
people are speculating like what are my
big like what does Tom specifically need
to respond to? Uh, there are three that
I know of going into this document
because I haven't read the whole thing.
Going into this document, there are
absolutely three big things that Tom
needs to address and debunk. There's no
like wiggle room here. Uh, number one,
age play. If he's in age play, that's a
non-starter. All right. Uh, glad I've
been friends with him for seven years.
If he's in age play, it's a non-starter.
All right. Second one, domestic
violence. All right. If he's hitting
these people without
>> So, there we go. Wait, wait, wait.
Sorry. There we go.
>> Let's run that back.
>> So, age play is a red line, guys. Age
play and Tom's done.
Okay.
Now, out of all the allegations,
the age play one is one of the more
substantiated ones. That's one of the
far more likely ones. Obviously, just to
remind you,
we'll play a Shimu clip. But just to
remind you, Aiden obviously leaked that
Lex apparently told him that Kai is an
age player and that she used to age play
with Tom. So, that's already uh not
looking good to say the least. But some
of the stuff with these girls is not not
great either.
>> All I know is Tom has a big dick. I
watched Nick's stream and he's just
talking about how Tom has a big hairy
dick. Hippie hoarder Sharusa girl he
sent dip pics to and got hacked was an
age play Bel Deline type girl
is a bunch of [__] about this girl as
well and her ex where basically They
broke up and accused each other of being
pedophiles and that she's like a massive
lollycon and all this [__] Um,
so yeah, just a a total mess.
So this is like one of the more
substantiated points of this really. So
I don't know how Nick, you know, it
really does feel like if I were to bet,
I would absolutely say Tom's an age
player.
I don't know why Nick set the standard
other than some like, you know,
consistency thing. I don't I truly
cannot imagine he actually gives a [__]
if Tommy's into age play. Like how
[__] absurd. Like really you would
cut off your friend of like 10 years
because what?
When he's [__] a girl, he wants her
to act like a kid or some [__] It's
like, yeah, that's gross.
But it's a [__] adult. It's
ultimately it's his adult girlfriend.
Like the idea that you cut off a friend
of a decade over that is so
just bizarre. Yeah. And then how do you
then that's the next step? Anti-age play
but CNC isn't a red line. It's both
simulation of non-consensual sexual
acts. Unless you just endlessly do the
[__] um kids but kids but kids but
kids when it's not even a kid, it's your
adult girlfriend. So I it's just like
[__]
It's [__] I don't think he actually
feels that way. I don't think anyone
would actually feel that way about a
friend of 10 years.
No one I've ever met in real life would
be that, you know, [__] sane about
one of their friends being like that.
>> If Chud and Nick go at it, you will get
brought up. If Nick called into you,
what would be your first words to him?
Hello, Don Dioro.
I
>> I don't know. It depends what the
context of calling in is. I guess
>> nothing wrong here. Thank you for the
$10. I'm obvious. Thank you for the $5
racist pedophile 88. Thank you. You
think Chud if Chud and Nick go at it,
you'll get brought up probably. But
yeah,
I don't think that'll be a call. Nick's
a [__] Anyway, what else was I saying?
Yeah. So, I don't think um someone
you've been you would Nick actually
cares about a friend of a decade being
like that. That sounds [__] to me.
Jstalk bangs destiny. Will Turkey Tom
get angry? I think so. I think he'd be
pretty upset by that. very jealous
>> area is really stupid because it's Kiwi
Farms that you probably went to the one
place where you'll find the least amount
of women in the Texas area. That's like
such a I think that a lot of this is
like scorned lovers [__] But that
doesn't discredit what they're saying.
It just kind of adds additional context
to the motivation because I don't
believe this is to protect any young
women in Texas. So totally totally
reasonable here. Nick's forced himself
to cover this and he is, you know, given
the the takes that you would expect from
accurate coverage of this
so far at least.
>> That's a big red flag. Sure. Well, I'm
not allowed to talk about red flags
because if I talk about red flags, then
I'm sweeping.
>> No one says that. Everyone else is
talking about the red flags in this
story.
>> Um, here's proof of identity are the
screenshots. Look, this this show the
read does show Nick's mindset, doesn't
it? Cut off Tom as long as he's not
sweeping, you know? It's like it really
is like
it is all it is is all about him. This
is where the sweep will be is the idea
that he would ever ever not have covered
this. You know, obviously I was going to
cover this when he wasn't going to. He
was begrudgingly whining about it in his
Discord.
>> Get bigger or I have to click them. How
does that work?
I don't know. Open image in new tab.
Forbidden.
What? Oh, can I zoom in? I can kind of
zoom in.
>> Nicholas the goat.
>> It's going to be a little smaller. It's
going to be a little small. Kill chat
box and wiggler until we're through this
part. So, here are the leaked text
messages from Turkey Tom. Um, Turkey Tom
is the one in the gray bubbles. I'll
explain everything later. It has nothing
to do with you.
>> Nicholas Dioro streamed about this last
night and after watching Nick's stream,
I'm kind of blackpilled on this [__]
All right, I'll
>> Where can I find a TT diss track you
played at the beginning of the stream?
>> Oh, it's awesome.
>> It's not a Turkey Tom diss track. It's
Turkey Tom. That's not AI. That's
actually him. Look up his t uh tipster
diss track. That's a real That's
actually an unironic thing that was in
his video. Um, okay. Hey, is everything
good? I don't know. I'll explain later.
It has nothing to do with you. Oh [__]
Scale of 1 to 10, how bad is it? I'd say
it's pretty bad. But it's just
unbearable, isn't it? It's just like uh
six straight hours of unbearable,
unfunny pop culture references.
I truly it it blow it blows my mind that
people enjoy this. Oh, I'm so sorry.
Well, an ex of mine got hacked and uh
basically there's going to be some [__]
that's going to drop online.
Some like photos. They already emailed
my family.
Oh, bro, it's okay.
I don't know if it is. I have no idea.
Has this ever happened? This has never
happened to me. At this point, did she
know that she was dating a YouTuber?
Surely by this point, she knows that she
was dating a YouTuber,
right? That's like
this is like I mean, clearly,
why mock the voice? Listen, Tinder
Capra,
>> we need to just get through this
quicker.
>> We do this every time.
>> I'm gonna have a [__] aneurysm.
>> This might be your first stream. It's
possible. All right, because we're
almost up to 6,000 viewers, but we do
this every time. Okay. Uh, is she the
one who looks like Bel Del? This is, by
the way, this is my close friend. I will
be doing the Carl Weezer voice, reading
his text messages. Is she the one that
looks like Bel Deline? Yeah. Lol.
>> Yeah, it's the one. Yeah. Do you think
my type is Bel Deline? No. Uh, no. Like
emo huz or that nature? I would just
pretend. I would prefer if you just like
dress normal. I don't want to be with
them anymore. It's better that way.
Yeah, this [__] does kind of make me
want to go to and hero a little.
>> Yeah, sub genius. I just don't
understand. Like I feel like
it feels like I'm the only one who sees
things this way.
And I don't understand quite why. Like I
feel like just being like accurately
describe the people you associate with
and criticize them as if they were some
anyone else, but you can be friends with
whoever. Is is that not a reasonable way
to think about things? But everyone else
is it seems like it has these standards
of association they've set up throughout
the years where they've said like, "Oh,
you can't associate with that person
because of this thing." And now they
have to like carry that through. I I I
feel that's what's happened is they've
called other people out for
associations. They've built up these
standards in their head being on the
internet
and and they have to like carry it
through
>> little bit. That's a [__] the he was
and hero video. I forgot that.
>> Always do the possible.
>> That's the guy who shot and killed
himself on uh video that was that was on
YouTube for a long time. Then it finally
went Yeah, it's a vintage meme. It was a
4x3 meme.
>> Oh yeah. Or is it just a business thing?
Am I just like not seeing that you
actually can't
you know, maintain your position if you
if you do that. Am I am I not seeing
something? Maybe. I don't know. But it's
fine. I must count my blessings. What
does that mean? I mean to kill myself.
Not really. Like, damn, this is
stressful and gay. Um, now again, this
is fine. This is okay. I guess this is
kind of here if I'm charitable to
establish the Beline character, BD2 for
short, uh, which I believe is the robot
from Star Wars. But the issue that I'm
having this already is the only thing
that I've learned here is that Tom's
dickpicks almost hit the internet.
Well, that sucks. I'm not I mean, this
is probably funny for some, but I'm not
like super stoked that we almost had a
111 for my boy. That kind of blows.
There's not really any Yeah, a BB-8.
Sorry. BB2 is BD BD1, BB2, and BD8. I
don't know what I'm talking about. [__]
it. I don't I don't know the sequel
trilogy. All right. I only watched those
once. Mer's got to make me watch them
again or something. BBL Drizzy. Yeah.
Again, all I learned from these first
two messages, and these are like the
only texts that we had for a while,
right? We got more actually down here is
like, "Hey, yeah, uh Tom's nudes are out
there and the hackers are apparently
really nice and when they blackmail you
and send it to your family, they don't
publish the rest." Uh, this first post
was soon followed by a few updates from
the X because the first X hasn't
provided her first name. She'll be
referred to as Sacramento from now on.
Okay. Uh, I promise all of this is real.
I could post more screenshots, but I'm a
little scared of him coming after me
because I'm a normal person. Um, I mean,
this is stupid, but there's a certain
level of charitability you have to
provide Sacramento because she's not an
influencer and she has no idea how this
is working. There's a certain level of
charitability you have to remove from
Sacramento
because she went to Kiwi Farms to war
young women. So, I think it balances
out. All right. I'm I'm inquisitive, but
I'm neutral.
>> I promise all this is real. Thank you,
Sacramento. I could post more
screenshots, but I'm a little scared.
I'm a little scared. I'm scared of him
coming after me. The next thing
Sacramento releases is a post. I should
just file this guy for you might think.
So, this is about the uh GI the JC file.
I'm not alleging anything illegal. We're
saying it was revenge porn or anything.
What I mean is he wouldn't ask before
proceeding to take his phone out
mid-sexual activity. So, this is a big
one. This is a big one that Tom's going
to have to answer for for sure. Serious
voice. sometimes would not like 15 to 30
seconds after he started filming. I had
no idea if this is illegal or not, but
yeah, he wouldn't ask before reaching
out. Sorry. He wouldn't ask before.
Reach out to an ex-girlfriend of his. He
would do the same thing with her. The
blackmail he has on his computer and
phone calls and texts. I believe most of
them are from his ex-girlfriend named
Kai. Here's a picture of when he matched
on Tinder. I don't have messages from
when we matched anymore. So, that's the
is that Yeah, that's a that's a Tinder
match. Uh, it was revealed that Tom is
alleged sexual blackmail and many of his
exes, including an ex named Kai, which
is concerning. Uh, Sacramento greatly.
It's what's revealed in his just in case
folder. So, if Tom is holding a bunch of
nudes in a big top secret folder to
deploy on command, that's probably like
a really bad situation. I don't know how
he would do that, but I've been in
situations where people do things that
are out of character and stupid before.
The only issue that I have with being a
is this assumption that's a sexual
blackmail folder is there's literally no
way for him to distribute that without
it getting back to him. If he
distributes these new pictures, she's
going to know where they came from. If
he distributes these from his main
account, he's going to be financially
ruined for the rest of his life. But um
yeah, he's going to need to address this
absolutely like what's actually in these
folders. Uh she then posts about him
being in contact with a thirst trapping
eirl despite being in a relationship.
I'm not surprised about this given his
stance on cheating. I am not inclined to
believe that it's not the case
specifically because he has like a
public position on cheating. The the
main reason I'm posting this thread is
to kind of warn people, mostly women,
about this guy. I'm not buying that. The
reason we broke up is actually because I
mentioned this website to him. I saw
some crazy stuff about him online and
his history with e girls bothered me.
The pic is about the Beline type girl
who was hacked.
>> Yeah, I saw PPP pointing out it does
feel like I said this to JTO as well. I
said it to JTalk and we watch King of
Casino and PP said the exact same thing.
I think I said it on my stream as well,
but if Tom said to this girl about this
blackmail folder he allegedly has, that
is just like you pulling some
implication [__] That is you saying,
"Don't cross me."
Why else are you telling a girl in the
early stage of a relationship about your
blackmail folder or about your
self-defense folder or whatever you want
to call it?
You're smart enough to know that's a
good idea.
So, you're smart enough to know what
that communicates to someone. Let's be
[__] serious.
>> Of cheating because you not block her
after the fact. And apparently she was
still um
>> assuming it's real. Assuming that
conversation happened, obviously we
don't.
>> I believe he's holding the camera in
mission area, but she doesn't really
digress on that. I shouldn't really
expand on that. Um so, you want him to
show his folder to you to clear his
name. How would you know if he deleted
anything? That's not I need him to
explain the nature of the folder.
There's no way he can disprove that he
doesn't have a folder filled with
pornography of X's, but he could try to
explain why it exists is what I'm trying
to say, if that makes sense. Uh he could
delete He could change everything, but
he can.
>> He's not like life from death.
>> That would go a long way. Otherwise,
>> I can't say it again, man. I'm risking
my channel every time I make that joke.
>> Link. Um, let me see. Nick, dude, wait,
what's happening? What's the issue?
Getting Louis McCllum flashbacks. What
is his stance on cheating? He's pro
cheating.
>> Um, what really uh what is this? I can't
read that. It's really small. What
really pissed me off is I spent a week
painting the poker table and they're
outside using it as a beer dye table.
>> Bulgarians can't be cool, edgy anime
guys. Okay, that's not how it works.
That's just not how it works. responding
to that. You can press charge. Oh, this
is about the leaked messages. Bulgarian
leaked messages.
>> Um,
let me see. Uh, you can press charges a
lot more. It'll be fine. I mean, uh, I
can figure out who it is. Yeah, it's
like seven pictures of me and my dick
out. So, he's confirming there are seven
pictures of his pean like on the
internet now. Well, not on the internet
that you can find, but imminent leakable
material. That's not good.
Um, she posted about his paranoia being
close to Kiwi Farms. Seems
foreshadowing, but maybe that's just me.
Like I said, he lied to me about who he
was. I figured it out pretty quickly.
Like our first date.
>> What does being Bulgarian have to do
with this? Well, to be honest, now that
you say it like that, it might be the
single most important part of this
story.
>> She did know by that point. Uh, he said
it was weird for a girl he's dating to
look at a gossip website. Told me before
I should never look it up online, lol.
The breakup was kind of mutual, but I
sort of crashed out on him in his past
with e- girls and dickpick thing. So, I
understand it. Um, he CLD probably used
my mini crash out right before Oh, he
probably used my mini crash out right
before our breakout against me, but
everything I said was truthful. So, I'm
confused.
She was mad that he [__] other people
or was she mad who he [__] Why? Wait,
why was she mad that his dick was going
to get leaked?
>> Like that his dude that's that's this is
kind of weird. They had a bad
relationship. We don't I don't know. She
hasn't said that so far. What's
happening?
>> It seems like they're pretty early into
their relationship. No, this seems like
it's just starting at this point at
least. I'm denying old allegations cuz
I'm in my early 20s. Okay. 89 username.
Are you 30? Are you 37 and dating Turkey
to warn other women? I've been in
contact with the ex since Tom and I
broke up. Yeah, she's aware I'm posting
on here and is actively trying to make
an account to post here as well. She
gave me permission to post these
screenshots. That's her IG Clorox Katie
after leaving his house and flying back
home bruise. So
>> this is a hookup. She's a girlfriend and
she's in her early 20s. Um Jesus. All
right. So there's a bruise on her cheek.
Close up. Twin a victim. San Francisco
International Airport. So that's the
bruise. So what's the context to the
bruise? Gotcha. That's not just saying
anything. I'm speculating what the truth
might be. My lips are sealed. Oh, this
is more Tom text me. Do we not? So he
like punch punch punch punch punch punch
punch punch punch punch her in the face.
Is that the allegation included with
your screenshots of more text saying DMs
with Tom post. So these are his things
and we're talking about flying out e-
girls. The thing is I can't complain
about the poster because this is how
it's formulated. But I want to know more
about that. But okay, gotcha. Yeah, it's
best not to say anything. I'm living
speculating on what the truth may be. My
lips are sealed. Yeah, it's less about
me like getting [__] I just don't want
you to end up on the Huey farmers pages.
Well, that's See, that's kind of ironic.
That's an ironic thing that's happening.
That's a bruise. Um I mean, I think so.
I'm not going to accuse or use makeup
within 3 seconds of seeing it, but I
guess anything can happen. Um
>> or is it something that was not
consensual at all? I'm just waiting for
a direct verbal here. My bad.
>> Because I don't know. Rough choking hit
me in the face sex could be two
completely different things.
>> She already said that. He didn't ask
this point.
Just like, "Oh, here's a picture of his
senior profile." She screenshotted the
physical match screen.
That's an interesting point to bring up
then I guess. Um, see screenshot match
like what is his bio what he did for
lift physio? You said he was a good Was
he a frequent specific kings that he
wanted to live out on you? Did he have
any real life friends he hung out with a
knew about his behavior? I didn't get
off who he was after. His bio was a
blank blank blank when I said a
biographer. His inner profile was mostly
pictures of him flexing. I could believe
that. Usually his phone covering his
face. I don't want to go into anything
legal but during sex is very rough. He
would choke to hit in the face. I don't
think anyone knew I knew about this. So
my question again is like this a
consensual action that we feel bad about
after the fact or is this something that
was not consensual at all like I'm just
waiting for a direct verbal here $5. My
bad
>> because I don't know rough choking hit
me in the face sex could be too
completely
>> maybe she shouldn't say at this point
she screenshot the match why that's a
good question. She then clarified Tom
tends to hit women pretty hard during
sex. Yeah he hit pretty hard. She
elaborates his porn addiction how
affected her sex life. He told sorry
that's what happened. It sounds like a
typical picn behavior. Does he have porn
addiction and was he harder stuff? Also
when did you find out about it? He told
me he was a porn addict who passed a
couple years ago. I believe your place
is pointed edition would film other
women during while having sex because he
was unable to ejaculate most of the time
during sex but only through watching
videos he would tune
this read this is like a parody. So
Turkey Tom would have sex with a girl
and he could not finish and then he
would [__] watch home videos of
himself having sex and he would finally
come. That is like [__] disaster.
That's a disaster dude. Turkey Tom
masturbates to himself.
>> Oh god. Guys, I'm not having fun with
this to be clear.
>> This sucks. This is not this is not a
good thing that's happening here.
>> What a weird virgin.
>> What a weird [__] virgin this guy is
huge ego. as soon as I read it.
>> I can't take it. I actually got battery
limit, bro.
>> I think too good to be true is not the
correct wording here because again, I'm
not looking for an excuse to hate Turkey
or should not turkey. But hey, man, he's
terrified of Kiwi Farms. I'm here to
save women. Um I might I um he's he
always had this page open. The minute he
found out about me looking at Kiwi
Farms, his penis just stopped working.
It shriveled up, turned into a prune,
and his sex life ended abruptly. All
right. Okay. I think some of this is
probably true. Just because I have
issues with this and I think there are a
gaming red flag doesn't mean that Tom is
inherently innocent of innocent of every
charged [__] internet allegation
here. But I will say that there are like
>> Nick just insulting me.
>> I understand why people are hesitant to
just go on stream and talk about this,
but it's like a mostly disjointed AMA
with somebody who's like a scorn.
>> Shout out to Nicholas Dorio.
>> Yeah. Well, you saying her story sounds
like [__] but here's the issue with
that. She absolutely does have a picture
of his profile. She absolutely.
>> Are you really act like watching
yourself having sex is normal? It's as
normal as recording sex tapes is. That's
that's within a pretty normal range of
activities. It's like not that crazy as
far as things go. Like yeah. Does
everyone do it? No. Obviously not. Is it
smart to do? Certainly not if you're a
content creator. Don't have that [__]
[__] anywhere. But is it like crazy?
No.
>> It's not a matter of if it's a totally
fabricated person. Never mind.
>> The reality stop for a second right
there cuz even if I see lot of problems,
this must mean it's fake. Doesn't want
me out pictures of them together. So
there's some aspect of this. Um, at
least the fact that they've met each
other in dated, that's probably
accurate. As for how much actually I'm
sure we'll say respond to,
>> okay, tell call me crazy for saying
this. Feel free to call me crazy when I
say this. Everyone had a weird as [__]
friend when they were like late teens or
something that was in some way too horny
relationship and was way too ready to
show videos.
Tell me I'm wrong. Tell me I'm wrong.
Call me crazy. Yeah, it's split half and
half. It's split half and half.
I've had co-workers do that.
>> Split half and half. So, I'm at least
not totally crazy
away. Um, yeah. So, he's penis clear
some small fling and they dated for a
few months. Okay.
>> Whoa. We dated for seven months and I
met his family. Let me get this
straight. This guy likes to sleep around
and browse brows before some random
chick he banged off Tinder. Is his mouth
he wasn't looking for anything serious?
Although it seems to be difficult to get
more evidence because he's careful about
what he texted.
>> Careful. Appreciate the shout out.
>> But dude, a seven month relationship
should not be. Thank you. your fake
name. Toify, if you're still here, stand
back and stand by and raise your head on
microphone, guys. Everyoneifi lower your
headphones. All right, there's
specifically raise them up. Thank you
for the call. You guys are in another
call. I'll see you on the other side. I
think it's going to happen. I'm getting
I'm getting off here. It's not
happening. Actually, turkey. We found
out we found his girlfriend used to
[__] kiwi farms, dude. This is what
it must feel like. I can see it. I know
it's coming. It's just not working. This
is Dude, what is happening? This sucks.
Are you guys reading my farm? The goat.
Why did that one go off? My reading my
kiwi farms get up. Can you [__] dude?
Please, dude. Stop reading my kiwi
farms. It's not working. Stop it. You
muted it. No, I didn't mute it. You
muted it. No, I didn't. I didn't touch
it. All right, as soon as I start
talking. All right, I'm going back to
the segment now. Okay, I'm going to go
back to the segment. It's hard because
this is going to play as soon as I start
talking. Can you please provide proof of
these allegations alleges sexual
priority? I don't think it's hard to
ask. It's hard because he's very careful
about text. And again, it's not like I'm
alleging anything illegal. So, she's
saying there's nothing illegal here.
That's interesting. I thought he was
because up until this point, we're we're
in order of events, right? If there's
nothing illegal here, then what about
like the recording without consent
thing? Does that imply the sex was
consensual? Sorry. Does that imply the
slapping and rough sex was also
consensual? Uh, he would hit choke
because he was a super goer. It sort of
I normalized in my Okay, this is the
context I wanted. Uh, but it's
definitely not okay to do that. All the
proof is in those videos you had. Refuse
to send me or ignore the question I
asked. Katie told me about a picture of
the bruises was due to injuries from
sex, which I believe because you would
slap both of us. I'm really sorry, guys.
Did you live together during those seven
months? Seven months a long time. What
made you stay if you sketching and had
red flags? Did you ever speak about
wanting to start a family? I like how
like, oh, we met you and also I need
more info than Tom. No, we didn't. We
don't see each other like once a week.
Usually pretty nice, but sometimes you
would say stuff questions and
intentions. You would buy me a lot of
stuff and take me nice places cuz I want
to marry me and our family, but soon I
started getting sus. It was like I
switch flipped. Okay. She also confirmed
to Tom's a certified cuckle that I
didn't even cackle. Another thing I want
confirmed is that Kai on him with
William not him 100% real and Tom moved
in with her after the fact. The girl
really [__] him up and he would still
see that during our relationship. Uh
while he might not have been controlling
his access contributed to his behavior
for quite a bit just in play only videos
just in case malicious more just in case
I am
>> Yeezy season 9 long sleeve sample
dude really cool stuff really awesome
stuff
>> and kind of thing is stupid seven months
would be less as careful
>> for fake games I do feel like donation
after spawn of this I'm taking a look at
my ticker it has not appeared in my
streams yet that's why it hasn't going
off for some reason it's delayed on
YouTube's end zone It might be because
of the denomination or like how much you
donated but that's never happened before
but I've seen donations be a little bit
delayed so I think
>> about rape and a dude who has a segment
on show called ultimate rape review
>> thing
>> um was he very insecure controlling how
he talked to you because this no
opposite like he didn't even care if not
to anything but yeah his feelings about
his accent control his behavior how long
ago did you date how long was his stuff
with Katie the age player girl we dated
from May 20 time May 25th to the end of
this month um Katie the age player was
2024 okay
um
>> have we gotten to the part where she
says it doesn't hurt anyone because her
cooter was beaten to the textures of an
Old C.
>> Shut the [__] up, dude. Thank you for
the $5, Gimmely. Thank you.
>> Despite telling his girlfriend that they
look like 15-year-olds, Tom, had ventil
sex with them. Oh, did you ever try to
impose his ex style on you like buying
you clothes that she would wear? No, he
actually tell me that he liked that I
looked normal while he was done with the
beauty types. I think one of the
screenshots or messages had him saying
something like that. I have no idea
about the gender of the girls. I'm
pretty sure they're all limited to my
knowledge. One of the things to add is
during one of our first date, he told me
I looked around 15 and he told Katie the
same thing. That's probably not good.
The man spends too much time on Discord.
That's a definitely YouTuber thing. And
said it was hard to tell the difference
between minors and adults. He taught
about any of his friends behind their
backs or anything like that. Oh, dude.
Am I being owned? No, not really. But he
told me a lot of you people are fake. He
doesn't actually true. That's actually
[__] facts. He was on Discord like
24/7. So what you're telling me here is
that Tom wanted to quit the BPD girl
epidemic and the first time he did it,
he got completely exposed on Qi forms. A
lot of people are saying that Tom went
the went the right way. He's going in
the wrong direction. All right. I think
the answer is just stop doing in
general. All right. Become a Catholic or
something. Uh cleanse yourself.
>> So this is like crazy and [__]
So it actually isn't the problem. Like,
yeah, if Tom did non-conensual stuff
and, you know, didn't clear
whatever physical aggression stuff
before doing it, that's all bad and kind
of like a separate thing. But for the
general lifestyle, for the general
lifestyle, it's actually really it's not
that big of a deal that you're like in
your early 20s bouncing from
weird relationship to weird relationship
with doing weird sexual [__]
That's actually like fine.
The problem is the [__] public
persona. Yet Nick chooses to go, "No,
the problem isn't the [__] public
persona." No, we should we should be
epic and tradically.
But you be epic and tried and Catholic.
No,
be a normal person, but get on stream
and be real. Get in your videos and be
real.
Don't pretend you're on some [__]
you know, high horse,
you know, covering Mr. Girl, acting like
how could anyone ever say this [__] when
you in relationships saying, "Damn girl,
you look 15." You know, if he did that,
have some [__] humility. Have some
sense.
Learn from your experience uh leaving
the house.
You know,
allow it to influence you a little bit.
Have that reflected. Don't cowtow to the
dumbest
unic [__] lesbians in your [__]
audience.
I'm going to keep you. CLEANSE YOURSELF.
CLEANSE yourself of the uh Yeah, dude.
God, what is the context? You mean like,
"Oh, baby, you looked I'm" I'm not
reading that. Which is uh which is
approximately how cringe I imagine you
talk all the time. Was like, "Haha, you
look 15." Kind of joke. To be honest, I
don't know how to phrase it. The context
was I told him he look older than his
age. He's like, "Yeah, he 15." Um,
because it's hard to tell at the age of
15 to 23. Yeah, don't agree on that one.
She then dropped a piece of digital
evidence that he detected that Tom would
hurt her during sex. Okay, be too
personal, but text about me being hurt
and bleeding after sex. I really don't
have much evidence because he was
carefully.
>> Yeah, exactly. Deep. As we all know, a
guy going Catholic fixes any sexual
perversion.
>> Um, oh my god, why is it so small? Okay,
never mind. It's here. Okay,
>> tell me [__] little boys if Nick gets
his way.
>> So hard and I bleed. Well, if you don't
have as much sex, you don't have to. You
can do other things. Okay, I like doing
other things, too.
>> Why did she post this? Hey, we're having
too much sex and it's hurting me. Okay,
we don't have to do that last night. And
after watching the next stream, I'm kind
of black and this [__]
>> Imagine being like Boogie and Logan,
scamming your audience from what we're
Ox.
>> I'm sorry. It's not even my thing. I'm
looking at Streamlabs right now. It's
not here. Thank you.
>> All that means is it's going to happen
at some point. I'm not prepared for it.
Let me see. Did it count here? Yeah, I
definitely count on Alex, but Streamlabs
is having a problem cuz I'm looking
through here. There's nothing even close
that nomination here. Unless it's the
MX. No, it's MX guy. What was your
>> max
um income? Yeah. No, it's literally not
here. It has not reached it. Can I
refresh? Uh,
all right. But I don't get this one.
This one looks like this is like, hey,
dude, we don't need to do it three times
in one day or do it so hard and bleed.
Well, you don't have to do that. After
this, she clarifies the bloodware deal
isn't any underlying health issue.
That's important. Uh was it due to me to
be uncaring or aggressive during sex
health issue you had? I have no health
issues. I know I've never bl before. It
was the aggression. Just gave into it
after a while and told him I liked it.
But okay, but can I All right. So, this
is more of the coping again. I'm sorry,
but um but you told him you liked it.
Why didn't you just cuz here you say, "I
don't like this." And he goes, "I won't
do it anymore." Here you said I liked it
and I was bleeding.
>> This is the issue I'm having here, but
whatever. Keep going. She didn't give
more cont.
>> So, that's [__] isn't it, Nick?
Because if she says, what she's saying
there is that she told Tom she didn't
like it. He said, "Yeah, that's fine."
And then kept doing it and kept doing it
and she just sort of gave up with
protesting.
Now, that's poor boundaries.
That's not how you were presenting it
just then. that was, you know, and
again, I'm not even accusing him of
sweeping here because
Nick is a very low IQ person at the best
of times and hearing him try and engage
with topics about relationships and sex
is, you know, like
I don't even know what you'd say. Like
it's it's like trying to get down need
to do like quadratic quadratic equations
or some [__] like it's just like not
happening. It's not happening.
>> Sexual violence affected her. Did you
ever give any sort after carried you
expect to get over yourself? You just
want to phone discord literally choke me
and hang him and make me bleed. I teach
him how to be nice after this initi at
the beginning. Okay. I believe the
bleeding was caused because you
basically just bleed bend me over it.
Choke me and then stick his dick into me
basically. So he didn't use like
lubricant I guess. Katie had the same
story reaching out to me and helpful in
understanding how bad this all really
was because I only had told my roommate
after one time. It was pretty rough.
Okay. Um
so this is a little odd too.
>> Nicholas the goat. Thank you for the $5.
>> Okay. Fish to walk on land.
>> So for seven consecutive months you
blend after every sexual encounter
sometimes three times a day. The example
you show is him saying like why am I
explaining cinematography and black
color and [__] So after this he keep
doing obviously sucks.
>> Gez communication is for chumps.
>> This is I I get why people of the year
the best com of the year worse than
RTX507i being cancelled.
>> Um then Tom's other x kiw left for dad
offering even more proof of degeneracy.
Hi finally made account. Yes Tom's
extremely harsh during sex. I have down
the king my linger. Okay. We don't need
to do it three times in one day or do it
so hard it hurts and I bleed. Well if
you don't have as much sex we don't have
to. We can do other things. Okay. I like
to do other things too.
Why did she post this? Hey, we're having
too much sex and it's hurting me. Okay,
we don't have to do that. And after
watching Nick,
>> okay, so Nick's even That's a subtle
sweep there. That's a subtle sweep,
isn't it? You know, I won't I won't
assume it to be intentional. He doesn't
say we don't need to do that. She says
maybe not so much and maybe not so
rough. That's what she says. And Tom
says, "Okay, well, maybe we can do other
stuff." So, she's saying maybe, you
know, let's tone it down a bit. And
Tom's like, "Well, okay. How about I
just [__] your throat instead?"
Basically, right? That's like, "What's
going on here?" It's like, it's not
actually complying really with the with
the ask, is it? It's like you're trying
to still almost like minmax
[__]
>> Imagine being like Boogie and Logan,
scamming your audience from what we're
OxD.
>> I'm sorry. It's not in my thing. I'm
looking at Streamlabs right now. It's
not the goat. Thank you.
>> All that means is it's going to happen
at some point. I'm not prepared for it.
Let me see if it count here. Yeah,
definitely count on Alex, but Streamlabs
is having a problem cuz I'm looking
through here. There's nothing even close
to that denomination here. Unless it's
the MX. No, it's MX guy. What was your
donation? I'm going to check cuz I don't
want to [__] you over. Um, income. Yeah.
No, it's literally not here. It has not
reached. Can I refresh?
>> Yeah. Desperate for head.
>> I don't get this looks like this. Hey,
dude. Do one day. It's hard. My curtain
bleed. Well, well, you don't have to do
that. After she clarifies that blood to
any underlying health issues. That's
important. Was it me on carrying
aggressive drink sex issue? I have a
health issue, but I know I've never
played sex before. It was the
aggression. Just gave into it after a
while and told him I liked it. But okay,
but can I All right. All right. So, this
is more of a coping again and I'm sorry,
but um but you told him you liked it.
Why didn't you just cuz here you say I
don't like this and he goes I won't do
it anymore. Here you said I liked it and
I was bleeding. That is the issue I'm
having here but whatever. Keep going.
Should give context how Tom sexual
violence effect after you expect to go
over yourself. You just want to phone
your discord choking and hit making me
bleed. I didn't teach how you knife
after this issue at the beginning. Okay.
I believe the bleeding was caused
because you basically just bleed over
it. Choke me and then stick his dick
into me. Basic. So you didn't use like
lubricant I guess. Katie had the same
dude. Brilliant. This is my favorite
part. This is my favorite part. It's the
best part of the stream.
>> Keep going. Should give more context to
how Tom sexual violence affected her.
Did you ever give any story after you
expect to get over yourself? Uh, you
just go on his phone or Discord,
literally choking and hitting and making
me bleed. I had to teach him how to be
nice after. This was an issue at the
beginning.
Okay. Uh, I believe the bleeding was
caused because he would basically just
bleed, bend me over, choke me, and then
stick his dick into me. So, obviously
the We all know the point here. We all
know the point here. Hopefully, I have
to explain it. We all know why Nick's
wrong. It's very embarrassing that he
did this and it's incredibly funny
because he was watching Chud's coverage
the day before because he was seeing
about it in Discord. He was watching
Chud's coverage. So, he saw Chud like
euphemistically explain what's going on
here and has tried to fill in the blanks
and has failed. It's [__] awesome.
It's [__] awesome, dude.
>> Basic. So, he didn't use like lubricant.
I guess Katie had the same.
>> Brilliant, man. Brilliant.
Brilliant. I love it.
You just you you you can't write comedy
like this.
>> Story reaching out to me has been
helpful in understanding how bad this
all really was because I only had told
my roommate after one time and it was
pretty rough. Okay. Um,
so this is a little odd too.
Nicholas the goat. Thank you for the $5,
my man.
>> Yeah, this seems kind of stupid. So, for
seven consecutive months, you bled after
every sexual encounter, sometimes three
times a day. The example you show is him
saying like, so my question dreamed
about this last night and after watching
Nick's stream, I'm kind of blackpilled
on this [__]
>> So, after this, did he keep doing it?
Was he pressuring you to have sex?
>> Gez, communication is for chumps.
>> I know. This is the I I I get why people
had issues with this part of it.
>> The Oreo commentator of the year. The
best commentator of the year.
>> Then Tom's
>> worse than the RTX507OTi
being cancelled.
>> Um then Tom's other ex Katie showed up
on Kiwi Farms that are named Left for
Dead, offering even more proof of his
degeneracy. Hi, I finally made an
account. Yes, Tom's extremely harsh
during sex. I uh have been down the kink
road in my life and how he acted is just
evil and sadistic. Not even kinkedked
up. Actually, like a Patrick Baitman
type goonaroner. If he survives this,
this meme will live on. First girl
already posted some of my screenshots.
If anybody has questions or want
specific proof, I'll try to see if I can
answer. Uh, Sacramento chimes back in
telling us to consider contacting law
enforcement.
Dude, wait, what? I thought it was
illegal. Wait, why did you, Dude? All
right. Um, so she came on farm, said
she's trying to save women on Kiwi
Farms, said that nothing was illegal up
here, I guess, and now she wants to talk
to the cops after leaking everything.
She went to, you know, usually we see
Twitter first. This is Kiwi Farms. Okay,
again, not discrediting her, just
listening. Red flag. That's Tom. By the
full disclaimer, I'm really close to
Tom. I'm super biased and I pretend that
I'm not biased. So, if you have any
issue with that, I'm just telling you
this is like not I'm not the stream to
watch if you're looking for somebody
who's not like going to [__] this up
probably.
Um, yeah, law enforcement telling people
that everything went down. Then I
blocked him after listing out every
single thing he did wrong because I knew
he would send my text lawyer. Katie's
back saying that Tom was just loving the
fact that she looked like a little girl.
>> I finally accept that. Uh, he also said
how awesome it was that I look like a
little girl the first time we had sex.
Told me he was excited to learn I had
BPD because girls with it love harder.
So, sorry.
>> Keep on appreciated the shout out.
>> I mean, listen, if he did that, that's
insane. That's absolutely awful. Um,
that would be like the uh what is it
called? The age player. That would be
like this worthy. Sure.
>> Um, she audio talk about Tom wants to
rape her.
>> Like
what?
Make a comment about how girls with BPD
love harder. That's gross and
embarrassing.
That's disavow worthy. You have to cut
the guy off over that.
What planet is this guy living on, man?
What planet does this guy live on?
Seriously, I truly don't understand.
>> Preferably, you should drive a new one.
I got upload everything my phone to my
PC. You guys, I got to get my phone. I
got crazy audio. I'm saying he wants to
night rate me, which I think he's trying
to say that is like negative RZ, but
it's insane to use that as RZ. Okay, I
clearly haven't read this before cuz I'm
saying this for the first time. She
updates us on how evil he is during sex
and how worried she was.
>> Test. Yeah, I don't know why the other
one. It's still on my own. She updates
us on how evil is dex and how worried
she was that he was going to beat her if
she stayed with him. Uh, capture the
thing. I'll make that right.
>> Nicholas the goat. Thank you for the $5.
My bad.
>> All right, so let me turn on him.
Obviously, he's done some [__] Uh, but
what moment was like, "Okay, [__] this."
I truly thought he was a cringe [__]
but who was definitely going to beat me
later if I stayed around. We only had
like a two-month fling, but even then my
insane ass was scared of how he acted
and he also was just stupid. I had a
conversation with him. What specifically
did he do? What proof you have? He's
extremely weird. I also evil [__] sex
again. I'm going to small with him. I
would fly out to see him. So, luckily I
witness a lot, but enough to tell you
guys and add validity statement. I also
randomly recordings of him every DM and
text message. So, this hasn't come from
life, but no, he's already basically
said that
>> guy doesn't feel great as a guy. What
type of guy is Tom and how is he doing
this multiple times a day? Does he have
a scarred uppery? Thank you for the
dono. Thank you. He already said earlier
he was like laying out the red lines. He
said it's like the age play [__] The
age play [__] he said was like a red
line. That was Tom's done. That's the
case. Again, there's like kind of a a
Dems moment here. But like I thought so
Tom's recording sexual encounters about
consent, but she's just recording Tom
without his knowledge. She reminds us
that Tom was really paying for the girl
flights including hers. He wasn't paying
for your flights. No, he was. She
reminds us that she was going to grab
videos and photos and dump them when she
can. So I think those are coming. Who
recorded this and why? Will she record?
I don't think he recorded audio of
himself talking about night raping her.
Is there any particularly interesting or
damning you have? I'm turning on my old
phone now. I grab the videos. I'll post
whatever. I think he's even something
relevant. Then we made a double posting
for both Sacramento and Katie. Um just
in case folder. Can you confirm or
corroborate? What would be in that
folder? And you know anything relie
so he told you it's phone calls and text
messages and you're thinking like oh
this must be a blackmail nude folder.
Okay. Um I mean I guess it's fair to be
inquisitive about that. Um but I would
have included that. I'm probably in
there too as well. How did you guys meet
initiate contact with you? So I already
followed him because I watch his YouTube
when I when I hit him when I broke up.
He immediately DM'd me on Instagram and
followed me told me I looked like Kai
and he clarified he definitely has some
weird issues related to her cuz he still
has all her clothes even after moving
multiple times since they broke up. She
let us know his hygiene is so ass
ringorm. Yesesh. He definitely smelled.
Well, I met him in person. I met him
after smelly. He smelled last time I saw
[__] ring ring ring ring ring ring
ring ring ring ringorm. She promises an
update when she gets all the details to
PC. How far are we? So we're about a
third of the way through. I assume all
the interesting stuff is towards the
end. There are DMs now that seem to
confirm he had ringorm. I'm assuming he
got ringorm from the gym though. Like I
think that if you're not wiping down
equipment and [__] or like walking
barefoot to the gym that's I don't want
to say common, but I think that's
probably where he got it. Yeah. What is
that? Um, oh, thank you for the goal. I
mean, yeah, I probably believe that. I
was kind of just going to go with that.
Please don't feel exactly that mistake.
I got to turn my old do how many posts
about turning on your phone. Should not
upload 10 two audio samples, both of
which are reuploaded in video form later
in the timeline and can be seen on the
media tab on the website. There's also
supplementary postings about this event
which can be seen on the supplementary
tab on the website. Here you go. So, I
kind of want to go to the media tab now.
Should I go to media? Where are we?
Right here. Okay. Media tab. So, these
are the night rape ones.
>> I'm a fan of night. Can you see this?
>> I'm a fan of night.
>> I'm a fan of night rape.
>> For real. For real. Yeah, I don't know
how much else to this we even care
about, dude.
>> What the [__] am I calling out patience
for this guy?
>> Well, I can confirm that's Tom's voice.
>> This sounds like every phone call I've
ever had with Tom. I can confirm
everything.
>> True. True.
>> All right, I'm coping a little bit. I'm
feeling a little coping right now, but
this is this is that is nothing to me.
>> I'm sorry. Wait.
>> I like this. It sounds like a It sounds
great. Yeah.
>> From Game of Thrones be like
>> So true. Oh my god.
Oh yeah, [__] it. Well, we'll stick this
in. We'll watch this again. [__] it. I
think we'll start moving on from Mr.
Dioro stream because I genuinely college
guy for him for extending period of
time. But we we'll play this liquid
Sonic thing we saw earlier at the end
for the segment here. So guys, Liquid
Sonic made a great little video here.
So, without further gray little video
here because Nick is trying to Nick and
his uh
new p new new batch of orbiters,
they're trying to reccon uh the rape
review segment.
So, let's take a look at that.
>> So, without further ado, Turkey Tom
ultimate rape review.
>> This video isn't to tell on people or to
hold Yeah. Yeah. Apparently like
he he Tom's talk when he says the elf
from Game of Thrones he means like these
children of the forest characters or
something maybe I
you know it does seem age playy it does
seem lollyconny
but hey old people accountable I ain't
about that this is done because there is
a sort of rewriting of commentary
history going on and I think it's
whitewashing certain individuals who
once used to salivate at the release of
a Google doc. This is the rape review
analysis. So, rape review. A lot of
people use this term now, and it's
pretty much what it sounds like. People
in commentary reviewing rape
allegations. With a quick search, the
earliest instance that I could actually
find of this term being used is Vosch
talking about how DG have coined this
term. Yeah. So, um, Destiny's been doing
this. It's sort of crassly being
referred to as the rape review. Uh,
where he goes over allegations. This was
for the method Josh the the Twitch, you
know, the method community stuff.
>> Rape review was coined because he would
review the rape allegation. This
>> sorry, were you listening liter like two
seconds ago? You stupid [__]
>> Should be pretty easy to understand, I
hope. And although it originated with
DGG, this guy Chlo,
>> this isn't this is like so close to an
instant timeout where I say, "Guys,
we're going to watch this again. this
thing we already watched in the stream
again for the segment and then three
people in chat going, "Did we already
watch this?"
>> Yeah,
that's what I said when I introduced it.
Yeah.
>> Pretty much yonked it and popularized
the
>> mindowing the Shan Head drama. We
covered the um FaZe rape review as my
community call it. There was that guy MW
got accused of some allegations. So we
looked at the that and talked about
that.
>> Chud started doing some really good
numbers reviewing rape allegations with
his rape review segments.
And soon many drama content creators
decided to copy the format. The person
who I think saw the most popularity out
of reviewing rape allegations was
Nicholas Dioro.
>> Dude, I would love to do a rape review
at Chudlo Logic where we just like live
react to like the newest rape. By the
way,
>> so what's that? a rape review where we
live react to the newest rape. Well,
that that does sound like a rape review,
doesn't it? And that does also sound
like what Nick and Chud do on stream,
right? I think we can all agree on that.
>> Guys, we're probably going to do an
ultimate rape review, if not this this
weekend, maybe early next week. Uh
because we haven't done Savannah yet.
And I know it's kind of a dead topic for
everybody, but I'm going to talk about
Savannah because I'm malicious. Okay.
Yesterday I had people over and they
were asking about what I do for a living
and I told them that I do it and
ultimate rape review and there is no in
between chat
>> to you know my content to be known more
but I don't want it to become more
wellknown.
>> This is not a liquid Sonic video.
This is just a little liquid Sonic extra
that he made. It's not actually a video
on his channel.
>> I was assaulted and then he did for the
first time by accident. Uh and I don't
specifically remember the actual first
time that he did.
>> I think it was consensual. No, no, no.
Hey, take the sexual element out of
this. I understand that we have to talk
about this cuz it's [__] rape review,
right? But even from like a casual, why
is he biting people? Do you think that
we should do that? Should we have like
three people who are set up to watch the
stream and then give like a uh a round
based score or whatever? Like a plus on
a on a 10 scale to see if the person
raped or not?
>> This is like um this like EAP for rape
connoisseurs, isn't it?
>> It's EAP for rape connoisseurs. That's
exactly
>> step one. Well, yeah, this this does all
seem like they're reviewing rapes,
doesn't it? It does seem like what's
happening here.
>> Party with Minecraft YouTubers. Step
two, question mark. Step three, ultimate
rape review.
>> You stole the meme from Chud. Chud
literally started like rape review after
me. I literally created it.
>> Yeah.
>> So, obviously untrue, but that's a joke.
>> But this is where history starts. There
was one time where somebody Googled and
read off my Wikipia like he hosts the
show Ultimate Rape Review and I go
listen, okay, I can try to explain this
to you. I'm not going to
swear to God it's not what it sounds
like.
So, can anyone steal man this for me?
In what way is rape review not what it
sounds like? I don't understand.
As far as I have seen, rape review is
exactly what it sounds like. A rape
happens.
It's talked about online.
You collect the evidence
and then you review it. I don't How is
that not precisely
what it sounds like when you say you do
a YouTube segment called Rape Review?
Yeah, that sounds pretty literal to me.
That sounds like exactly what it says on
the tin.
Yeah, maybe there's like an extremity
where someone might interpret as being
like you're literally reviewing a video
of a rape. You're not Yeah, I suppose
you're not putting them on a scale out
of 10, but as far as what it's
communicating, no, that that is a rape
review.
It's exactly what it sounds like. There
are now these newcomer channels that I
don't think it's right to judge, but
they're claiming that Ultimate Rape
Review is a satirical name for a show,
and Nicholas Dioro does not review
rapes.
>> You don't have any valid reason to
criticize this on. Then he characterizes
these detractors as being rape reviewers
when they're not. And hold on, hold on.
We we'll get there. If you know, you
know. We'll get there. So, of course,
Nicholas Duru does not do [__] rape
reviews in the literal sense. He uses
that word in a very internet speak
manner, but I'm not surprised that
people would hear about it and assume
the worst. However, after watching some
of Nicholas Dioro's VODs over the past
few months, I recognize that Ultimate
Rape Review is a satirical name and the
segment highlights how YouTube drama
consistently turns other people's trauma
into content.
Huh?
What?
No, you don't understand. It's actually
a very intricate satire.
Very intricate intricate social
critique, social commentary, talking
about the way the internet works.
No, it's actually just Nick doing
exactly what you just described, just
turning other people's drama into
content, which again, as said earlier,
totally fine. You can do that. I do
that.
Totally fine. No problems there. But
don't pretend that's not what you're
doing.
Let's not pretend that's not what's
happening.
This is a factual inaccuracy. If you
ever want to make a claim like this,
just load up Filmont first, search a
couple terms, and see what you can find.
It's all right to get stuff wrong, but
to Princess Mantis, and that's okay, T.
I think it would be good to make a
little retraction in whatever your next
video is. Just say, "I made this claim
about Nicholas Dioro and I was wrong. It
turns out Nicholas Dioro loves rape."
And just a year or two ago, he used to
love to review rape allegations on his
show Ultima's Rape Review. And that is
fine. Really, I think it's lowbrow. I
never watched any of the Minecraft Rape
again and stuff because I don't really
care if some random person that I've
never heard of did or did not rape
someone else. But Nick, he bloody loved
it. Simple request, really. Any honest
person would want to add this to their
next video and then the history books
will be corrected.
Wow.
It's a great little ending there. Great
little ending.